[Music]
jeff is going to start us off this hour
in cincinnati hi jeff how are you
hey jet
i'm i'm doing good dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up
well i'm kind of a new follower i just
found you earlier this year
had some questions about potentially
refinancing our house
we originally bought it back in january
of 2021
this is obviously before we knew you and
we we got a 30-year loan
at two and a half percent
and now
kind of considering do we move to a year
but my biggest concern with that is
that we're giving up that two and a half
percent rate to
go somewhere around five percent or so
you're right
i would not i would not do that you're
right
okay no you can you keep this
keep the existing mortgage you have
if you calculate a 30-year mortgage
and you calculate a 15-year mortgage at
the same interest rate in your case two
and a half
and you pay the difference
like you like you took out a 30 and you
pay the extra amount as and the
difference between a 15 payment and a 30
payment it will pay off in exactly 15
years
okay you do not have to refinance to pay
a loan off in 15 years you just have to
pay it like it's a 15-year payment and
it'll pay right out
or more of course and then it would pay
out even sooner so never refinance just
to move from a 30 to a 15
because you take on the closing costs at
a minimum and in this case you'd go up
an interest rate so you never do that
just pay extra on it and you'll get
there
okay
that was easy wasn't it as far as
as far as how much uh like house i can
afford
we were well within the
25
um kind of calculating it off of a two
and a half percent rate that we have
great um
but
with rates now i know we're not
refinancing um but that would obviously
put us
probably closer to the 30 mark do we
have well it doesn't matter you could it
doesn't matter you're fine you know the
reality is your house payment is a
fourth of your take home pay at a 15
year
on two and a half and so you're fine
the reason we put that in place is not
to keep people from buying homes and
john people are really mad right now
about hate home house prices apparently
i hate home ownership and i'm an
unrealistic old
um boomer or whatever other terms of
derision you can throw at my bald head
but the um
i don't care if you get a house you
can't afford it doesn't affect me it
affects you if you buy a house you can't
afford jeff's in good shape he's not got
any issues but
here's the thing and i've been answering
this question the same way for 30 years
like we have people call us from
california well dave you know you can't
buy a house in california for that uh
that means you can't buy you can't buy a
house that's california for that that's
what that means
you also may not be able to buy bentley
uh you also may not be when i grew up
this county that we live in is the 11th
wealthiest county in the nation the
wealthiest county in tennessee
williamson county tennessee where you
and i are sitting right now where both
of us live now when i was growing up
that's where the rich people lived
and we said stuff like you can't afford
to live there
and you know what not everybody can
afford to live there you know i could
afford to live on rodeo drive or in
downtown manhattan or downtown tokyo or
downtown london it's freaking expensive
and so sometimes you just have to say i
can't afford it number one but number
two here the reason for this is we know
from the data of doing this for 30 years
that your most likely
way to become wealthy is to get your
home paid off as soon as possible and
all other debts too
because it frees up your most powerful
wealth building tool and so if you keep
a mortgage around like it's a pet
for your whole life because you're
thinking well i'm always going to have a
mortgage and the only way i can afford a
mortgage only i'm ever going to get a
house because i'll never get a house i
never get a house i'm so stuck and it's
just not fair and life's not fair and
i'm a four-year-old on the cereal aisle
throwing a fit and i want captain crunch
dad blame it you know and it's just like
and you just everybody's acting like
that right now
and so i'm sorry you i'm i'm sorry that
when i was a kid i couldn't live in
williamson county i couldn't afford it
my family didn't make that kind of money
i'm sorry i had a traumatized childhood
i'm sorry
but it's the way life is and so you know
the answer is no the reason you tell
yourself no is so you can tell yourself
yes later
so if you go buy a house you can't
afford
and you go take car payments out that
you can't afford and you go take which
nobody can you go take out a student
loan and you go take out mastercard and
visa and american distress you're going
to be normal and normal is you work your
whole life
and give all of the money you earn to
someone else in the form of payments and
retire broke and hope social insecurity
will take care of you who the crap wants
to be normal right
and so you've got to break this cycle
and not be angry
at me or at the world or at instagram or
twitter or whatever it is you're angry
at this week
um because house prices went up
i'm
really sorry i i don't want you to
be upset i don't want you to not have a
house but i also don't want you to do
something stupid that's going to keep
you broke your whole life
i'll throw a third one on there dave
i have found in my life when i've had a
30-year mortgage and i've had a couple
of those in the 15 year
i can have all the best intentions with
a 30-year mortgage
but when it comes down to it
every single month somebody invites me
out to a thing or hey we're all going
out to this thing
and
whether i've got the best intentions or
i've got all the willpower in the world
it's really hard for me to make that to
double that payment or to make that gap
payment between the 30-year note is
requiring me to pay and what i could be
paying for that 15 year
with the 15 year i'm locked into it i
got to do it
one of the things i figured out when i
very first started doing this stuff with
financial peace when i started studying
rich people is
they put
smart things on autopilot yes i don't
want to think about it 100 of the
15-year mortgages pay off in 15 years or
less yep a hundred percent or they get
foreclosed on i mean 100 of them do okay
people that take out a 30 promising to
pay a 15 the studies say 92
do not
stick with the schedule i would say if
you if you put a system in place that
you have to be in the top eight percent
is the only way you win you lose you're
gonna lose that's dumb i just was
listening to some obesity researchers
today and they were talking about step
one create an environment where you can
at least attempt to be successful get
the junk out of your house yeah right
you can't have it all there and say i'm
gonna make good choices because you're
not gonna make a choice james claire
talks about that in atomic habits yeah
talks about the exact same thing what is
it you're trying to create a habit then
don't put stuff that's contrary to the
habit right in front of you the opposite
of paying the mortgage off early uh and
another autopilot is the 401ks that's
why they're so successful you never see
the money it just comes out of your
check automatically are an auto draft on
your checking account for your roth iras
or your kids 529 you autumn you're an
automatic investor and david
bachman had a best-selling book
automatic millionaire or whatever it was
called uh and he said just put
everything on automatic and you know
what there's something to that and so
quit do quit thinking you're like have
superpowers just to get to buy crap you
can't afford it's a bad idea